get Maggie tell her he's awake
you
[Music]
hey everybody I began all kinds of
Defenders questions about the ending so
I might explain what's going on the
stories that they set up for the other
shows daredevil in particular there is a
daredevil season 3 so here we go just
careful for spoilers if you haven't seen
defenders yet I was surprised by the
number of people that were asking me
questions about whether or not there
would be a daredevil season 3 there was
a teaser they released at comic-con 2016
over a year ago so I think that people
just forgot about that because it was
just a title treatment was like hey
season 3 coming really soon but no real
official word on that
so because the end of defenders sets up
all the different characters next
season's like Jessica Jones season 2
Luke Cage season 2 daredevil season 3 we
know what's going on and they drop a
really big comic book Easter egg that a
lot of you have already picked up on so
it sounds like what happened is this
Elektra sort of came to her senses a
little bit like she recognized how much
she loved daredevil at the end there and
dragged him out of the rubble remember
she has superpowers kind of like Luke
Cage and Jessica Jones now she's on par
with them so it's not too outlandish to
believe that she survived the fall and
protected him a little bit enough so
that she could drag him to where he is
now healing it whatever convent he's at
if you look outside there's brick he
could be out of the country he could be
somewhere inside the United States and
the others will fill the gaps they will
protect his city like Iron Fist wearing
his Iron Fist jumpsuit as he wakes up
one of the nuns says go tell Maggie that
he's awake so all of you big daredevil
comic book fans probably spotted that
and said wait a minute
Maggie are they talking about Margaret
Murdock as in Daredevils biological
mother who is a nun in who he met for
the first time during the daredevil
bourne-again storyline 99% sure that
that's what's happening for daredevil
season 3 they'll adapt the born-again
storyline because it's sort of like the
rise of the Kington the last time he and
daredevil faced off or he and Matt
Murdock faced off he said that he would
tear him down not as daredevil in this
moment here he was telling Matt Murdock
that he was going to destroy him but he
also wants to destroy the devil of
Hell's Kitchen for helping put him in
prison in the first place so if you
haven't read the born-again storyline
it's a big Karen page arc and it's a big
daredevil versus kingpin story are
his mother is a big part of it so when
it says born again it's him at his
lowest point he has this come to Jesus
moment remember there's a lot of
religious iconography Catholicism woven
into the DNA of the daredevil character
so all of his stories have religious
elements to them so he doesn't die
during that comic book it's just that
the kingpin systematically destroys his
life in everything in it so that Matt
Murdock effectively doesn't exist so he
metaphorically kills Matt Murdock and
daredevil without literally killing him
but as born-again implies the character
is born anew and it's sort of a way to
refresh the character and had this big
reaffirmation of his purpose and what
he's doing in the city what is my cause
how am I going to go about this mission
so it's sort of like a soft reboot of
the character and that sounds like what
season 3 is going to be but you wonder
Karen page is a big part of that
storyline there's probably going to be
liberal changes to the way her
character's written into that story
because she's hardcore addicted to drugs
and she's either selling her body or
she's starring in adult films but she
has no money and she's so desperate for
another hit of drugs that she goes to
the kingpin and sells out Matt Murdock's
identity to him just so that she can get
more drugs so it is one of the worst
examples of throwing a character under
the bus could you even imagine what
would happen is they did that to Deborah
Anne walls character her Karen page is
very different from comic book Karen
page you guys can let me know in the
comments do you think that they'll do a
version of that where Karen page winds
up inadvertently being responsible for
letting kingpin know who daredevil
really is and then he starts tearing
down Matt Murdock's life as he gets out
of prison but obviously we're talking a
lot about kingpin he hasn't been
anywhere in defenders and there's a
couple more series that will drop before
daredevil season 3 so right now they're
getting ready to shoot season 3 so it
takes them about a year to turn it
around so that means next we have
Punisher coming in November then we have
a Luke Cage season two Jessica Jones
season 2 in then daredevil season 3 so
it sounds like all three of those will
drop next year so I'm assuming Luke Cage
will be first because I believe they
filmed that first then Jessica Jones
will drop or it might be the other way
around and then daredevil around maybe
November December but some of those
dates could shuffle
a little bit but let me know in the
comments what do you think about the
idea them doing born again for daredevil
season 3 I think it's an easy slam-dunk
and honestly of all the Netflix shows
regardless of what you think of them I
feel like they have the easiest time
riding daredevil daredevil has just been
a much bigger character in the comics
than any of the other defenders but what
they're doing with all the shows not
just daredevil season 3 is opening the
door to more crossovers so like Luke
Cage and Jessica Jones popping up on
each other shows that was what their
scene at the end was all about be sure
to keep in touch so keep in touch just
means that she might pop up briefly
during Luke Cage season 2 you got
friends one of them yeah maybe we'll
grab a coffee sometime or something so
everybody including iron fist is getting
a new season in the interesting thing
about iron fist I'll do a longer video
about this it was an arc in the comics
where daredevil asked iron fist to
become daredevil for a brief period
while he was out of commission so that
was kind of what you're seeing happen
when he tells Iron Fist take care of my
city and then you see the silhouette on
the rooftop that you think is daredevil
for a minute like they are very
purposefully making this look like
daredevil until the fist lights up and
you see him wearing the track suit so 1
that's the Iron Fist comic book costume
a lot of people haven't picked up on
that I'm surprised I haven't heard more
people freaking out about it but I think
it's because he's not wearing the
headpiece in two he's taking over for
daredevil while he's away so you'll see
him running across rooftops there's a
lot of parity between the daredevil and
the Iron Fist character in that they
both defend the city the big difference
between them is all the crazy celestial
Iron Fist mythology that they've only
just started to push in so I'll do more
videos about that too because there are
a bunch of big comic book changes too
Iron Fist backstory and how the capital
cities of heaven shall allow work into
it the ideas about Chi how the hand was
formed there were a lot of really cool
things that they did but it sounds a lot
more complicated than it actually is
the producers confirmed that they're
leaving it wide open for other big Iron
Fist things like the capital cities of
heaven so they're not going to nail that
down right away what
you're more about that when we get to
Iron Fist season 2 but what's going to
happen next is there'll be a new Game of
Thrones we actually found out that we
might get season 8 next year there next
to some really good news they start
filming really soon so I'll do a video
explaining that and then obviously my
episode 6 video so let's say
congratulations to the latest Marvel
giveaway winner Wollstonecraft please
private message me on the back end of my
channel so I can get your contact
details it was a new round in this video
all you have to do to enter is be a
subscriber leave a comment on this video
while you wait for everything you can
click here to rewatch that punisher
trailer and you can click here for brand
new Game of Thrones thank you so much
for watching everybody stay awesome I'll
see you guys tonight